a nearby school sixth college of the
University of California San Diego
announced that they were gonna name the
college after me which is unbelievable
yeah and I was blown away I heard about
this and when I heard about it I was
under the impression that this was gonna
be a permanent name change yeah that the
college was going to be Conan O'Brien
College for all time just before I went
down there I was notified that it was a
change that they're making for 24 hours
I gotta say I was a little bit I was all
balanced right half an hour right like I
thought this is gonna be like carved in
stone yeah and then just before I go
down they say well it's a 24-hour deal
and it was on the weekend yeah why are
you making it were rubbing salt into
Hyneman detective anyway I thought Who
am I to make a come on this is a great
honor anyway 24 hours so I said you know
what I'm going and they invited me to
visit their school on this historic day
and I brought some friends along to
record it and well here's what happened
[Music]
just got on the train for my big
adventure this is just like Harry Potter
only my parents aren't dead
play Quidditch I'm headed to a magical
castle otherwise it's just like Harry
Potter
[Music]
look at this guys check this out this is
a beautiful early temporary sign what is
this this is my sign this is it my sign
calm down
no one did anything this is not what I
expected no no please don't worry about
it somehow it's appropriate so this is
being published on the brain college
though this is a nice ring to it doesn't
it I went to Conan O'Brien College set
the guy in jail
how many kids here at Conan O'Brien
college do you feel like they live up to
the spirit of Conan O'Brien the values
that Conan O'Brien has definitely hyper
hyper I was hoping you'd say yes they
have integrity hard work honesty hyper
they've got an overactive thyroid
she's done you know
what happened to this guy how are you
thanks for being clothed
can you help me out with that so you a
student if Connor O'Brien college yes
you're asking Conan O'Brien if he can
help you yes no could you paint this how
did you know what my torso look like
we've just shown me the room where I'll
wait before I get my performance you can
see it's the same room where Bazar and
his children were shot
[Applause]
one question for all of you what the
heck do you mean maybe the college after
me for one day
the impression that this was going to be
a permanent change to the name of this
college and I get here and everything
that says Conan O'Brien College is
written on a dry erase board
gonna come right off and tomorrow it's
the Zac Efron library it should be all
perpetuity total Ryan College because I
change things
alcohol would be free
but I really love your hairs had a
question about it
yes is there some special maintenance
that goes into keeping it perfect and
Orange would you like to touch it step
forward step
get in there
tell them what in really Orange
alright with all of your experience and
education what is the best way to
approach a hard economy for a job
I came here to have fun there is this
yes next question if the world was taken
over by zombies what would be your
strategy to survive
finally a question that makes sense to
me
I think the best thing to do would be to
go to a place that has a big supply of
food it's in a fairly remote location
I'd head to the Denver Airport a lot of
food there feeds a lot of people it's
fairly remote plus zombies will be
confused by that conveyor belt on it and
it's going the wrong way
go spend hours and hours thinking
they're coming after you
[Applause]
hi are you frightened come on up here
come on just sit here with me
with you people
wondering how would you ask the girl
that you like them and how would you
dead with them if I liked a girl how I
approached her yeah
is she here tonight no well dude I could
have hooked you up if she was here
[Applause]
does she know you
yes you know with me no no I don't mean
she sees you outside her apartment
sometimes the last parts have a resume
for my work so I'm sorry if I could
become an intern that takes balls I like
it bring it forward what's this for
let's see special skills
stalking masks much of me you don't
understand that you want me to fix up
your love life and your professional
career you guys have no shame
you get me a girlfriend in a job
and it did surround this droves gonna
hit you to head move it
yeah hey guess what schools not named
app - after today
[Applause]